Last time we, uh, got into Canto 10,
and they began with the heaven of the Sun.
And that began with the
description of a Dante begins.
We went over the phases of the candle.
Uh,
on the one hand,
the is the description of the trinity,
of the inner life of the trinity is
a life of love or the breadth and the
father. The Spirit, um, love the son,
the father abound by the breadth of love,
uh,
as it were, then Dante moves into, um,
it's the description of the spectacle of,
uh,
of the whole or this
heaven and of this Po,
this fragment of the cosmos by
turning to us readers twice,
asking us to look up.
Uh,
it is by looking up, we can see, uh,
the givenness of creation. The fact
that it has been given a, it's,
it's a gift to us. Uh, it's
also a way of, uh, if it's,
if it's a gift,
um,
if there's any economy,
a theory economy in the cosmos,
it's a divine economy.
It also means that some are
somehow we cannot really claim to,
to own it.
That's,
it seems to be a natural consequence of
something being a Gif does not imply,
there's not entail
unnecessarily ownership of uh,
this gift that has been given.
And therefore we,
we are invited to have an aesthetic,
uh,
admiration over it. Uh, so this,
this kind of the scene
of, uh, of, of the divine,
this even a kind of field drama,
divine drama,
I spectacle that I'm folds and unfolds
throughout the course was answer with a
description of a,
the encyclopedia is a,
as I was describing it to you are there
is to say with a Kleiner's who recounts
a the names and mentions one
after the other, the twelves,
um,
representatives of various disciplines.
We talked a little bit about,
uh,
Solomon and the scandal
that his inclusion here,
uh, cause, cause in Dante's
own times and say it,
Dante's responding to a real crisis about
our knowledge of the ultimate fate of
Solomon, the wisest of old man. Uh,
was he saved or not,
uh,
on account of his weaknesses
in terms of his, uh, his,
what he's Letteri. Um, and then, uh,
the Canto focuses on ends really with
a CGL broadband who was a logician
philosopher. And Dante describes him, uh,
really owned the way to two knowledge. He
was ahead of thick. It was viewed of as,
as,
as a heretic.
Dante dismisses that whole charge.
And in many ways he
represents that knowledge as,
or the circle of knowledge is one of
made of a contradictory voices were those
that had been blaming CGIAR Oprah bands
such as Aquinas himself now retract
their positions.
So the whole process of getting to know
the world is one of Evers and it's one
of retractions. Okay. Uh,
there are some interesting details
that I could up. I could even,
I think that I should even
mention to you, uh, as a,
as we approach 11 and 12, uh, uh,
seizure is described as his,
uh, absorbed in his grave.
Thoughts in Italian is,
uh, uh, Graffy pain.
Sierra, you know, the Word
Been Sierra is that, uh,
English bends pensive, uh, and,
and I think that that is
such a remarkable, uh,
word because it really
means to think in Latin.
Uh,
and the oldest exploit this
residence of the verb means to be,
to, to be at an impasse, to be
suspended, literally to be suspended.
So he suspended in thoughts as if the
thoughts could not make him reach,
uh, the threshold of,
uh, the knowledge he,
Eh, he wanted. At any rate,
that's the way our can talk. 10,
that's the economy of
cancer. 10, I want to,
or since the three canters
that go together to really,
I ask you to turn to the end of
Canto 12 where our Bonaventure,
who is a Franciscan, uh, you probably
know what, what is meant by that.
The Franciscan is one in the order of
some Francis just as Aquinas is Dominican.
The Franciscans are those who believe
in the priority of will and love in the
act of knowledge.
Uh,
the Dominicans or is New York is Tutelian
like Aquinas believed in the priority
of the intellect in the
apprehension of the world.
The Dominicans were founded with
the explicit mandate to teach in the
universities were Harrises,
they thought abounded and
therefore they had to exit prey,
pluck off the roots of
Harrison's different systems.
We're going to be a
witnessing in the world, uh,
in both orders are,
are shaped by a belief in poverty
that we have to examine a little bit.
We have to understand what
it means at any rate. Uh,
Bonaventure he is a Franciscan
and by the end of Canto 12,
after it has been, uh, uh,
chronicling the life of, uh,
Dominic,
this is sort of another case
of extraordinary openness
of in Dante's view of
these characters in the
sense of Franciscans and
Dominicans were really at odds
with each other, both in terms
of their theologies and their,
and their premises.
Uh,
more intellectual premises above or here.
Dante has a Franciscan tell the life of
Dominic just as earlier in canned to 11.
And Dominicans and Aquinas
tells the life of Francis,
the two candles are controlled,
but what we call a cosmos, that's,
that's this is a cast was from the,
the Greek word Chi. Uh, he, uh,
uh, cosmos, right?
So you have an intersection
of, uh, of voices.
It's sort of a sense of the
interdependence of the two perspectives.
Um, I will say a little bit more about
one adventure after I read this paragraph.
This paragraph, the last
paragraph in Canton 12 lines
one third and following, uh,
uh,
sort of functions as a counterweight to
the description of the encyclopedia that
Aquinas had given at the
end of [inaudible] 10 and
ending with a seizure of
broadband. So let me just
see who the people are here.
I'm the living soul of Bonaventure of
binary area who in gray offices ever put
last?
The left hand care here are Luminato and
Augustan were among the first bare foot
a brothers in the code made
themselves God's friends.
Then a theorist of medieval encyclopedias,
hue of some Vic victor,
a Parisian,
a Fryer,
um,
who really wrote the so
called data scarlet going,
which is a text about what is the, what
are, what are the stages of education?
How does the mind come to the knowledge
of God starting from the small,
uh,
elements in the outside life,
the material world than
the interior lights,
etc. Before reaching
the God's supreme light.
Then a is here with them.
Peter, the bookworm,
Peter the Spaniard and other theorist
of medieval logic who shines below in 12
books. Then Nathan the prophet,
how come back to this name?
The Prophet Nathan is
known to those who know,
uh, as being, uh,
David's a bad conscience
or good conscience,
the one who is freaking
him to think about himself.
Nathan a profit,
uh,
sensor councilor of the king.
A little bit more about him in a while.
And Chris Os Thumb,
the metropolitan meaning that God with
a golden mouth language here is the,
the flower of eloquence
is what he processors. Um,
and Anselm the another theologian
who writes about the reasons for the
incarnations, right?
Famous Texas. But why do,
why did God become a man?
And then Donatos who then to set
his hand to the first art grammar.
So you say of the whole array,
the whole wide spectrum of water.
We called encyclopedia
logic, eloquence. Um, uh,
grandma Donatos is the, a Reuben
grump Syrian and there are banners,
a historian and beside me shines the
Calabrian Abbott Joke Him who was endowed
with a spirit of
prophecy, the growing, uh,
courtesy. And we'll judge it.
Language or brother Thomas.
I've moved me to celebrate so great.
A Paladin and with me have
moved this, uh, company,
uh, one eventual ends with uh, uh,
the tip of the hat and the
direction of, uh, Aquinas,
whose example he has followed.
So an example of a,
once again have a dialogue and openness
between the two olders in the tool,
the tool members of different orders and
yet in somehow interdependent with each
other. Uh, now, uh,
the presence of Abbott Joel Kim is another
counterweight to seizure of broadband
in Canto 10. He to joke him, uh,
who you have met because I talked
to have mentioned his name to you in
discussing the prophecy, glossing the
prophecy of the DXV improved at all.
You're 33. You remember where I
tried to explain it, that, uh,
that seems to be a kind of
apocalyptic meaning to that prophecy,
the numerical enigma,
a,
an enigmatic prophecy about the coming
of Christ at the end of time who will
come and therefore, uh, the,
the prophecy of the consummation of
history and the consummation of time,
the DXV,
the 510 and five is that is called.
And I said that the, the, um, the,
the joke is the interpretation of
that emblem of that symbol, uh,
seemed to me to be accurate.
They really meant really,
so to introduce the
idea of the end of time,
however I rejected,
I ask you to also reject the
implications of that prophecy.
Uh,
Joe is prophecy.
It was viewed as heretical for
a number of important reasons.
It expresses as whole to of
impatience about history.
This is a really believes
first of all in the, uh,
imminent and closure of history. His, the,
the end is close at hand. Uh, and
this is a kind of, and, and the,
and they ended up history
in prize, the, uh,
the coming into being a Va. And Utopia
and utopia of the spirit. The third day,
age of the spirit when
finally old institutions hold
barriers are shattered and
torn down. And this is a
kind of, this is really what,
what from Dante's point of view would
be wrong with a [inaudible] cause you
topian impulse the idea that it always
begs a foreclosure or what we can never
really fathom, which is the world
of, uh, uh, historical occurrences.
But another reason why he was viewed as
heretical by exactly the Bonaventure.
It was Bonaventure who asked
that his views be damned.
And now he is Soto of,
uh, writing a pilot.
Nord Dante allows him to make amends
for the previous condemnation.
Bonaventure found objectionable,
the ideas of a joke and move
forward because Joe came.
The factor is this solving the whole
notion of the utility of the trinitarian
life. He had, he, he theorizes, Eh,
an idea of history,
a tripartite idea of history.
According to the three persons of
the Trinity, the age of the father,
the son, and the Holy Spirit.
He believes that it is.
Once that was once in biblical times,
there was the age of the father,
God was understood this, the father.
Then we enter the age of, uh,
of the sun,
uh,
brotherhoods of all and now the
spiritual age of the Holy Spirit. It,
the factory means that the three ways,
the three manifestations,
this kind of complex way of understanding
a unity from different viewpoints is
actually, um, uh, uh, dissolve. This is,
it becomes separate each, uh,
each person of the trinity,
it becomes a separate entity.
And that view from four,
four Bonaventure was sa, uh,
heretical. He condemns him.
Now he acknowledges that he
actually was Abbott Joel Kim,
who was endowed with a spirit of
prophecy is something only prophetic.
In other words, what
seemed to be heresy, a,
an intellectual question
of, uh, of, of, um,
of thoughts and opinions and our
peers as some divination about,
uh, uh, things to come.
Uh, no, no, not, no,
not specified any further.
Retrospectively,
it's down to himself with legitimizing
drove him and therefore also legitimizing
his own position.
In Canto 33 a of Purgatorio Dante
shares the view of the apocalyptic,
the new mom of history.
However, uh, he refuses.
He rejects the idea that it's
possible to establish a, uh,
a for such a,
an occurrence joke him appears now
is a visionary among, among them.
The other figure that I would like to
say something about is Nathan the Prophet
for a very simple reason, because
Nathan, as you probably know this,
it's very strange. Why would that
include Nathan a prophet among, okay,
there's joke him of Florida was prophetic,
but why include Nathan among this? Uh,
why spirits? I mean, he could have chosen
so many others. He would have chosen, uh,
uh,
those who actually have written and
whose shoes works are canonical in the
Bible. He doesn't, uh, he chooses Nathan.
And the idea is I think
a little bit of, uh, Eh,
an autobiographical or pun about Dante
himself because the ne Nathan the word
Nathan means he who gives,
in other words,
Dante Soul in the name of Nathan,
his own name.
And he plays him. Yeah.
That's what Dante means.
He who gives Nathan becomes a kind of
mask for Dante of it is as if you were
saying head I did,
if I had I and other life
or a pasta must live in,
uh, the heavily apotheosis. That's
where I probably would like,
that's what I,
I probably will end up certainly that's
what I would like to be so innate and
there is a mask for
himself. Now. Why? Um, uh,
what is this?
So also peculiar about this encyclopedic
ordering of the arts and the sciences.
It doesn't really differ
very much from Aquinas,
but it's interesting that it's
Bonaventure who, who, who,
uh,
articulates who voices this kind of a
who celebrates all these names and all
this arts because Bonaventure is himself
a theorist of the encyclopedia very
much as you have some victor.
But he has one crucial reflection at
the beginning of his encyclopedia.
This is that the activity
of knowing and learning,
it's like going up and down a ladder.
And you might say,
you read that metaphor. You might say,
well, that's an extraordinary metaphor,
but it's the metaphor of the
ladder of Jacob in the Bible,
which is where he probably
found that ladder of Plato.
And that's where this idea that,
uh,
we ascend the mind a sense
when we learn something,
when we get educated,
the mind goes up and which we can go down.
But the interesting thing
about Bonaventure is that
he goes on saying that as in
a ladder,
the lowest rung are always more important
than the higher ones because without
those, no one of us will be
capable to climb up the ladder.
So the lowest, the lowly, uh,
forms of knowledge, grammar,
uh, the, the,
the external lights of the census
was he distinguishes his, his, uh,
it's theater of knowledges
as a proliferation of lights,
as a universe of lights, internal,
external lights, internal lights,
that light of the sensors.
Uh,
the lights will come to us from
books and the light of God and so on.
So we are always going to be
enlightened in our process,
but as we are enlightened, the lowest
lights are first of all, self sufficient.
They are those who may not be capable of
ascending, sending much higher, uh, in,
uh, in the, in along the ladder. Uh,
then the first few wrongs that is a really
a self sufficient knowledge that they
can acquire.
So the arts have to him the art of poetry,
that's the lowest rung and yet
that has its home self sufficiency.
And then you can go up the ladder,
then literally learned more. The,
the interesting thing about that ladder
is that there is no sense though.
It establishes a hierarchy
in that hierarchy.
The lower elements as crucial
as the higher elements.
Because without the lawyer there,
the lower rungs who live with a kid,
I never really, uh, can
go up to the end. The,
so, uh, this is, uh, another
image then it the finally,
let me just say with, uh, uh,
with the jaw came, uh, uh,
the inclusion of Joel Kim. Uh,
here we are getting into the,
uh, the Eurasia of, uh,
a strict barriers,
strict boundaries between
what is heretical and what is,
what is canonical. I think this is
the salt of, of openness, uh, Dante.
So openness, uh, that somehow
reverberates with, uh,
the lesson of Francis and Dominic.
And therefore,
now let me turn to those two
cancers. Keep in mind, and,
uh, as we read the Canto
11. Good. Again, I, I,
Eh, I repeat in the heaven of the
sun and I don't know that, uh,
the passage that I read to you from
the pseudo ionizers last time about the
divine names, where this will be the
United States goes on talking about, uh,
uh, uh, why is the
metaphor of the sun such a,
such a,
such a fundamental emerge for
the divine divine generosity,
right? This is, uh, as, as,
uh, an image of, uh, uh,
the sun that always gives of itself
without ever asking anything,
anything back. So it's a, it's
an activity of a purely general,
pure generosity.
Um,
and I think that's a Franciscan image
of a also of poverty to which a world,
uh, but which I'll talk
in a moment. The to 11,
I repeat ends with the
extraordinary, um, uh,
encomium of seizure of broadband
by a counterpoint can talk 11,
uh,
has an apostrophe against a
logical legal forms of knowledge,
the kind of knowledge that tries
to define the world in formulas.
And so he, Dante begins and this is Dante
speaking on his own in his own voice,
all intensive care of mortals.
How vein or the reasonings that make the
beat that wings in downward flight one
was going after law and
other after the aphorisms,
one following the priesthood that are
seeking to rule by force or craft,
one set to robbery and
another on affairs of state.
We're laboring in the toils of freshly
delights and another given up to either
lose what I set three from all these
things was high in heaven with Beatrice
received,
uh,
received thus a glorious way.
I think it's an interesting counterpoint
between these icons of power,
uh, that derive from the
study of law and logic.
And then the on the
other hand, this, uh, uh,
Dante's own self reference to
himself as free from all of this.
Uh,
this concerns.
I think this idea of freedom will
be the dominant theme of, uh,
of Canto of country 11
who, uh, it continues.
And when each had come back to the point
of the circle where it was before that
the two wheels of dancing,
old man holding their hands
around the sun as well,
which is a metaphorical son so that the
university is not even [inaudible] is
not heliocentric Dante's universe.
They're going to move now beyond the sun.
It stopped like a candle on its stand.
And then there is a little
prayer here and uh, uh, the,
the introduction of the two Dominick and
Francis lines three and following the
providence or rules the world with the
council and whichever he created site is
vanquished before it reaches the bottom
in order that the bride of him who with
loud cries whether high with his
sacred blood should go to her beloved,
secure in herself and faith, faith
fuller to him, ordained for her,
for her behoof to princess
to be her guides on the side.
And that the one, uh, was
all seraphic in order.
And that's Francis.
The other for wisdom was on earth.
And Splendor of Cherubic light. I shall
tell over the one since two praise one,
whichever we take is to speak of
both for the levers where to one end.
That's really the, the
formula that, that, uh,
seals the sense of the interdependence
of intellect and we'll,
uh, of love knowledge and
of the two the two voices.
And now this is the,
what we call a hagiography or a legend,
the life of a saint, the saint's
life of Francis, which is told by,
uh, by, by Aquinas, by
the Dominican Aquinas. Um,
where we are told is first of all,
between the two P on the water that falls
from the hill chosen by the blessed to
Baldo hangs at fertile slope of the lofty
mountain from which Roger feels cold
and heat at porter solar.
And behind it not sharing,
while do grieve under a heavy yoke,
it's an extraordinarily localized
representation of Francis origin.
It's a typography. He was
born as you know, in a sec,
but it's almost as if he were just placing
him in a specific place near the gate
that leads, that are on the
road to Audra. So season period,
very precise. Uh, and
it's called Puerto Solar.
More about this in a moment from
the slope where it most breaks.
Steepness, son. Now we
go from the top anemic,
the name of a place,
the gate of the sun,
Sunday this gate of his son to a
metaphor for Francis as the son.
He is the son.
So we are in the heaven of the Sun.
And now Dante Invest Francis with
all the attributes of this celerity,
this continuous steady giving of oneself
as the sun does and the new platonic
imagery, the mystical
neoplatonic imagery of, uh,
of the sooner the United States
is Sun rose on the world as this,
that sometimes from the Ganges. Um, uh,
so as soon as we,
Dante has mentioned the specific
place for Frances birth,
then the coordinates of the geographic
coordinates completely change.
We go from the specific and
local to literally the global,
the world of the Ganges,
the orient something a little faster as
if the son Francis really acts between
the concrete and local and,
and, and the widest, uh, uh,
possible, uh, reference.
Therefore, let let him,
who makes mention to that place,
not say ashamed, which means I,
I rise,
but it's panning with a CZ four.
He would say too little but orient
if he would name it a rightly, uh,
so it's uh,
uh,
it's an extraordinary emerged
and to astronomical terms.
The Sun and the Orient a four
four Francis' was Francis'
appears as like just as
the sun does as one who can,
and I'm,
I'm playing with the texts it
a little bit, but not much.
One Who orients us,
one who supposed to orient a re orient us.
He's born in the,
in in Assisi and yet it appears
as if it were the east where his,
what Dante is implied I think is that
that for those who go on the face of the
earth and lose the ways,
then Francis becomes one who can
tell them how to find the way back,
whatever they are going.
For those who do not know the way I told
her known never known the way they are
capable of discovering it.
He is providing this slide.
So what is this light that he provides?
What kind of light does he bring out?
He was not yet far from his rising.
The metaphoric of the sun continues
when he began to make the earth feel,
some strengthening from
his mighty influence for,
and now he gives the
story of Francis Life.
Um,
and before I go there,
I just want to tell you that Dante and
I brought a translation of a poem Nanta
that Dante knew that Francis
is an extreme, is a great poet.
He's actually,
we consider him the first port of
in Italian and Italian language.
I just want to read a few stanzas from
the so called Canticle of brother son so
that you can see how uh,
Dante zoned metaphoric derives
straight her with Franciscan visions,
Franciscan spirituality.
He begins most high.
It's a prayer, a canticle of
brother's son, our own powerful,
good Lord. Yours or
the praises, the glory,
the honor and old blessing to you alone.
Most high do they belong and no
man is worthy to mention your name.
Praise be my Lord with all your creatures,
especially Brotherson who is the dean,
who is the day and through
whom you give us light.
And his beautiful and
radiant with great splendor,
embarrass her likeness of view.
Most high one praise be Yuma load through
sister moon and the stars in heaven.
You form them,
clear and precious and beautiful praise
bu my load through brought the wind goes
through all the four elements.
And part of the,
the suggestiveness of this poem is
that it's a song of praise to God,
clearly enough. But it is also,
we never know if uh, if, uh,
Francis is thinking of these
elements, the sun, the moon, the wind,
the water death itself as the medium
through whom he can praise or the cause on
account of which you should
praise or the or the agents.
And the Italian is very ambiguous boar.
Uh,
for those of you who may know a
little French or a little Spanish, uh,
four by through,
uh,
this is so there's a kind of
extraordinary require an orchestration.
The other thing that I should mention
is that finally we can understand the
rhetoric of praise that is
running through this poem,
but we also saw as a disc this,
the describing the rhetoric of
praise in Dante's Vita Nuova.
When he finds out that the best way of
writing about Beatrice is really trite,
uh, uh, uh, praise poems,
not actually which he distinguishes
from flattery, but praise poems,
the poems or praise means in many
ways rejecting all sense of ownership.
Realizing that,
note the fact that one may know the
world doesn't mean that one owns it.
And also it means that not
knowing Beatrice is not
just a cover to wish to own
her.
So the praises as disinterested in this
free and mode of a acknowledgment of
Beatrice herself. Let's see how
this continues. This whole, uh, uh,
poetic vision of Francis continues with,
uh,
with canto 11.
Dante goes on giving us the life
of Francis and he catches fray.
Frances England is in what I would call
using the language of anthropology,
really, Eh, liminal stage. You know
what I mean by the liminal stage?
There were liminal comes from the Latin
a threshold or comes from the Latin for
uh, limit the two words, many
ways, very contradictory, but it,
it has the power, uh,
Lehman, uh, uh, is one thing,
meaning meaning threshold but
also the word or make also limit.
Uh,
so the threshold may be a limit and the
threshold may also be an opportunity to
cross a way of going over,
I call it dentists use here.
He does use the word limit several times,
not in this context.
Dante places, uh, Francis in
eliminate opposition. They,
this would say between and between east
two different orders on the one hand,
the world.
And on the other hand,
some kind of a utopian
idea that we never win,
which would be the older he goes
on to institute or some, uh,
general vision.
But what the world ought to be.
He places Francis in between,
uh,
neither part of the world.
No part of this final utopia.
And let's see what he does
in this liminal position. Uh,
that's where he catches him.
And look at this lines here.
I'm still a youth. Uh,
this is the biography of,
of Francis are modeled on a number of
biographies or where it existed at the
time. Um, uh, foster youth,
he ran into strife with his father
for a lady to whom is to death.
None willingly unlocks the door,
which is as extraordinarily
difficult line to translate.
The Italian really could be read to say,
unlocks the door of pleasure,
um,
and before his spiritual court.
And now he uses
a Latin phrase,
which is illegal formula and has the
value of a legal formula golden pathway.
They say he marries this woman.
We don't know who she is yet in the
presence of his own father that's giving
legitimacy to his, um, his act,
the act of marriage, um,
uh, caught on potter.
He was joined to her and then his
fourth loved her better everyday.
She bereft of her first husband Christ
despise and obscure 1100 years and more
remained without a suitor till he came.
Not they did a veil when
men heard that he was a,
He who put all the world and fia found
her a moved with a meatless at the sound
of his voice.
No,
there are very hard to have such
courage and constants that were married,
stayed below.
She mounted the Cross with Christ,
but less I proceed to darkly taking a
Francis and poverty for this leverage.
In all I have said,
the harmony and happy looks movement who
love and wonder and sweet contemplation
and let them let them totally thoughts
so that the venerable Bernard first went
barefoot and when after the great peace,
a running through himself too slow
or welfare known and fruitful.
Good. So, uh, there is clearly a reversal.
A Francis Mayor is poverty and you're
kind of that marriage to poverty.
We have to understand what in a
moment what that is. A lot of wealth.
A lot of Richard's, uh,
can be produced a clear,
a clear turning of uh, uh, whatever
intentions he may have had.
Uh, and, and, uh,
the great consequences of that act of is
what is this representation of Francis?
Um, it's, I think in
this liminal position,
Frances is shown as he is turning upside
down all the values that the world
holds there. So, um,
he wants to marry nothing,
right? Poverty to marry,
poverty's to Mary, nothing you, Mary
to be, you want to use yoke yourself,
you embrace owning nothing but that
marriage or that union appears as a
sacramental act. So he's making
fun. He's parodying better.
Just that we are a bit more is,
I don't want to imply at all.
And they blasted him here,
but he's paddling even the sacrament
of marriage he's marrying and nothing,
it's not a legal person. Uh,
some, some agent poverty, it's,
it's just an idealization or an allegory
for nothing. But that is conducted.
That ceremony is conducted as
if it were a sacramental act.
Not only a sacramental act,
he's in the law because he's marrying
poverty in the presence of his father.
He undressed, he divests
himself, all the clothes,
which in the Middle Ages as much as now,
oh Rustin,
for some form of symbolic status,
the way you,
you know, you dress according to the
job you want, they usually say, right,
but at the se.
But what I meant to say is that dresses,
clothes are part of a
social set of values,
which Frances is flouting and patterning.
We have,
we are in the presence of the, of the
Oba legal language, sacramental language,
even the language of love. At one
point, that language of sexuality,
the idea of Marin poverty talk
and does not, I change the,
the, the, the translation of
that phrase, the way Saint Clair,
because it's a little bit our tortures
even in Italian. Then we think clear, uh,
uh, hesitant or he says, none
willingly unlocks the door.
That I'm willingly is the door
of pleasure. Even sexuality,
which is certainly a value of the world.
Francis will turn it around.
This is a radical critique of
the value system of the world.
Call it a prophetic mode of a,
of abandoning the,
the,
the idols of the world in favor of some
kind of a utopia or unexpected Dora.
And, uh, really, uh, not clarified,
not very well described, uh,
uh, uh, vision of how the
world ought to be. But this is,
he rejects all of us.
So she bereft of her first husband caught
pattern he was joined to for fourth.
Loved her better everyday.
She believed her first husband despise
and obscure 1100 hundred years and more
remain where to suitor till he came.
No did a veil when men heard that
he who put all the world in fear,
found her a moved with a meatless
at the sound of his voice.
No did avail ha to have such courage and
constancy that well Mary stayed below.
She poverty mounted on
the Cross with Christ.
Even she does something even
better than what Mary does,
but less they proceed to darkly taking
a Francis and poverty for this lovers in
our lives that their harmony
and happy looks like.
This is another pattern of
the language drove of the,
of the amorous discourse of medieval,
medieval love poetry. Uh, uh, they go on,
he just said he's dead limbs with nothing.
So they have now finally an inclusion
of an extraordinary known value because
that's what poverty is. Something
that questions whole values and it's,
it's, it's a Franciscan idea of
poverty. What do they mean by that?
What did Francis mean by this? By this
idea of poverty? What is the sport?
First of all,
you know,
that the subject became part
of an extensive, uh, uh,
iconographic representation on what can
think of, uh, uh, the jaw, tall frescoes,
the cycles, a Franciscan
cycles in a Cz, but, um,
but all over Tuscany and Umbria,
Umbria by the way. So it's, uh,
it's not a unique and a r two,
Dante,
Dante's understanding and Dante's insight,
this sort of representation
and fascination with Francis
and other little detail
that I should tell you is that Francis
in Italian is Franchese schools,
meaning that he's French. And
there was the, like Francesca, ah,
the other franchise and the other one
who also understood a lot about love but
lost her way. Uh, in, in, in Canto five,
it really means free the word. In
English, we have the word frank,
which in many ways carries over the
estimates of the Latin word Francisco's
Francis true to his name
is now as being poor,
absolutely free.
There's no bondage to anything.
There's nothing that holds
him to anything in the world.
So this is one important,
let's call it ethical
extension of poverty,
but what did they mean?
What did the other Franciscans like
Bonaventure was there listening to what
appliances may say about,
about the founder of his older.
What did they understand by that?
Because whenever we talk about in
Dante's certainly seems to a stress,
the idea of poverty being poverty in a
very material bodily way called pauriol
physical in the sense, I call it
prophetic in the sense that as you know,
what distinguishes the,
the,
the biblical prophets from other profits
is that they usually shoes to bear on
their flesh.
The signs that they
oughta against the world.
If they want to speak about the,
the,
the infidelity of, uh, of Israel,
they would marry a prostitute.
If they want to denounce the,
uh,
dissidents Harris's and lacerations
within the, the body politic of Israel,
they would even go on cutting off an
arm of their stool to dramatize own the
flesh. This idea of, uh, uh,
this prophetic pronouncements
that were making,
this is part of what Francis then is
doing here and this idea that he's living
poverty. It's not just an allegory
is an allegorical representation.
It is something live in the flesh.
The literal India Lego Richele are now
compressed, but it's more what did,
what is, but what does, for instance, uh,
Bonaventure think of what poverty is.
Dante,
I repeat things about the material,
the of poverty.
So we way of opposing average
a way of opposing, uh, uh,
practicality, attachment or
contempt for the, the, the values.
We have seen that all of that before.
The poverty to them also
means poverty of language.
Francis,
the first one tool to have articulated
even that poem of his repetitive,
the same simple formulaic,
uh, expressions,
praise be omnipotent, et
cetera. Road that says, ah,
repeated that it's a poverty of language.
The poverty of our thoughts that which
Dante at the beginning of Canto 11 has
been calling the defective.
But that is the word that I, I,
I did not stress when
we were up. Uh, oh, um,
intensive care of maltose. How, uh,
vein our reasonings. No, no,
no. How defective the, the,
the Italian originals is how defective.
I hope some translators pickup defective
and make it a and say that it's the
fact defective in the idea that
they are lacking, that they,
they have nothing of their own so that
retrospectively you can understand what
I'm talking about. That we cannot
own the world. That this is a,
that the world is a world of
gifts, uh, that, uh, that, uh,
the economy is an economy of giving,
a constant giving because the more you
give and the less you have of yourself,
the more you are free and
they're more productive.
Your own acts can become as
well the case of Francis,
that this is no role that Dante we'll
do with a Francis. This is now, um,
there is one,
a little reference that I want to mention.
This is around lines 102.
Um, or saw a friend's is a, we'll go on,
uh, trying to have this, um, um,
to receive a seal of approval from
the pope's about the fraternity,
the older,
the confraternity,
whatever that he organized when the
comparable poor brothers increased behind
him. Who's wondrous life where
better song in Heaven's glory.
The holy purpose of this. Chief Shepard
was encircled with a second crown.
But the eternal spirit through our
Norris on Oreos agrees that pope or no
worries agrees to to
recognize this new order.
And now listen to this.
That's really the point that I,
that I want to stop on for a while.
And when in thirst for martyrdom,
he had preached Christ and them that
followed him in the proud presence of the
salted and finding the people and ripe
for conversion and not being willing to
remain for search for no purpose.
He had returned to the
harvest of the Italian fields.
They are on the rough crag
between Tibor and Darren.
He received from Christ the last seal,
which is members both for two years.
He's alluding to the famous story of
the Stigmata that Francis received.
The body becomes a sign. Uh, what I was,
I was trying to explain with the
reference to the Hebrew prophets who,
uh,
dramatize they are the [inaudible] and
legitimize the validity of the message by
an inscription of that
message on the literal, um,
the physicality of their own flesh.
And the tied to live with that,
that point though, that Dante is making
this, this story of the Stigmata,
but it's also the story of Francis who
tries to go and preach to the salted,
he fails the heaven, the
theological argument, uh,
and the tool, the sultan
and Francis Depart, um,
uh, each, uh, on, on his
wife, on his way. Uh, and,
and that's it.
It's a story of that can be understood
apparently is a failure of Francis'
message you.
But at the same time,
it is an extraordinary hermeneutical
term that has taken place in Dante's
thinking.
We have had and we will have
a celebration to the Crusades.
Now we have an,
a story of an encounter between Christians
and Muslims in terms of peaceful
language,
peaceful speech where the two exponents
or two of the exponents of the
particular beliefs can come
together and encounter.
And they can discuss the salt and says no.
Um,
for him you are not ripe and for
the salt and progress as well,
then you know what you're talking about.
And uh, and they, and they leave. Okay.
So this is an extraordinary
change in, uh, the,
uh,
dissemination in the dissemination of
violence that had been at the center of so
much theological discourse and he had,
Dante seems to be a opting in,
following trends is on a different route.
This is I think,
an important change in,
uh,
in the consciousness and the historic
understanding of the relationship between
Christians and Muslims and other
interpretations of the Crusade.
But there is a further detail
that I want to mention here. Um,
uh,
the,
the detail is this detail about our two
geographic coordinates in this cancer.
Now we have just read about
Frances trip to Egypt and the salt,
right a little earlier,
Dan,
to give the ref refers to the birthplace
of Francis by talking about the Ganges.
Okay. So, in other words,
Dante has is aware that there is a
European world that we talked about last
time, but there are two
other, two other coordinates,
one a Hindu world of the Ganges and
we shall see what that means for him.
And the other one is the most
of them world of the salt. Him.
He's acknowledging in many
ways that which was, it's,
we probably may not be entirely
familiar with this, uh, this problem.
He's acknowledging that
which, uh, the, uh,
someone like Bonaventure
had been discussing in 1273
Bonaventure the men that we
shall see next in the next Canto traveled
to Paris to give a number of lectures
at the University of Paris.
He will die a year later in
1274 and they're called, uh,
uh, uh, conferences and
number of conferences, uh, uh,
in which he just debates the question of
the relationship between what he calls
the, these three cultures, Hindu,
the Christian and the Muslim and ties to
see in what way they can be harmonized.
He connect,
it's Bonaventure connects the Hindu
religion with George [inaudible] in the
sense that the joke him of the third age,
not complicated at all.
You remember the joke him has this
paradigm of history are according to a
tripartite structure, the age of the heft
of the father, the son and the spirit.
The third age,
which is his own age,
the age wouldn't burn eventual lives when
Dante lives is the age of the spirit,
implies the elimination
of all institutions.
The idea that the spirit now is
everywhere and there is no need for any
hierarchy.
Any Bonaventure says,
this is exactly the world of the Hindus
who believe that God is everywhere.
And then he goes on talking about,
he Bonaventure talks about
that Muslims for who, who,
whose theology is a
theology of uh, uh, Eh,
an impassable distance between God.
Transcendence that nothing could
really bridge between a god who remains
invisible and the world of every man here.
Of course for him,
the mediation between
the two is given by the,
by Christianity because with,
with the idea of the reset transcendence
and at the same time an imminence of
God and the transcendence of God,
Dante is I think,
echoing this texts and this
problems in the Canto of Francis.
So he praises Francis between the Ganges
and Egypt and praises him as the one
who is a carving, a new space, the
space that he calls that have poverty,
meaning freedom, meaning the
will meaning the way of love, uh,
as a way of coming to the
knowledge of God. Um, then, uh, um,
I would like to move on to,
uh,
very briefly to canter 12 briefly,
not because I ima not, uh, uh,
I'm insensitive to what,
uh,
what Dante we'll do with Dominic and
cantor. 12. We really haven't got time,
but I want to mention to you
a number of things. Uh, how,
uh, the encounter with the Bonaventure,
uh, told, uh, we're, I'm sorry,
the encounter with,
uh,
with the description of Dominic told by,
uh, by Bonaventure, uh,
really rewrites the previous Canto there
in the previous can't have a friends is
where the marriage, uh,
periodic, uh, kind of, uh, uh,
uh, an archaic idea of, uh, uh,
the valueless ness of all the world
that he values a here though we have a
different wedding, a different
marriage between, uh,
Dominic and faith between
knowledge and theology.
If you want to put it at a
very generic and general level,
uh, and he, uh, to, uh, that is
the, let me just go over with, um,
uh,
lines and 45 in that part.
Let's say it'd be the description
of the legend of Dominic,
that life of Dominic in that part,
we're sweet.
Zephyr rises to open the
new leaves in which Europe,
once again, see how dentists,
there's a kind of continental,
uh, imagination here,
the, the Asia, Africa,
and uh,
in Europe,
the three continents in which
Europe sees herself reclad. Um,
not far from the beating of the waves
behind which the son after his long
flights sometimes hides himself
from more men lies. Favorite color.
Hora uh,
you love this detail.
I know that I can tell
by the way the, the, the,
the eyes of some of you smile when I
pointed this, this, uh, this thing,
Dante's talking about the
birthplace of, uh, of, uh,
of Dominic and places, which
is where it was in the, uh,
western part of Spain. They
are where the sunsets. Okay.
So the Dominic becomes
the counter to Francis.
He was born with the sunrises and now,
uh,
Dominic is within with the sunsets.
Okay. So between the two of them,
the whole movement of the sun, the trans
slash CEO, that translational faith,
not the translation of empires,
not the translation of
cultural translation of
faith seems to be encompassed
between the two of them.
But that which will make you
smile is that Dante mentioned. Uh,
and you can check Francis birth in the
east where the sunrises and line 50 of
Cantwell 11,
and he mentions the setting sun of
Dominic in line 52 of a canter 12 as
emphasis. There is a kind of me,
there's a, uh, the, the, this is,
this is a kind of rule.
I think it's, uh, it's,
I've had a bit of music touch
between them. So uh, uh,
talk to account for the,
the,
the difference in proximity between
the two as if this movement.
So here's a kind of,
the movement of the sun from east to
west on account of them has its own, uh,
quickness. It's own rhythm. Um, okay. Um,
and then in it was born the loving
Leachman of the Christian faith,
the holy athlete Greicius to his own
and Peter is two enemies and he's in his
mind as soon as it was created,
was so full of living power
than his mother's womb.
It made her prophetic when the spousal
between him and faith were completed at
the holy fond.
Here there is another marriage ceremony
that counters the previous marriage
ceremony Motivo Canto of Canto 11.
But I want to draw your attention
to the use of this playful images,
the athletes of of faith,
the Leachman.
In the previous candle we
had a Francis who I said,
pat of this or the values of the world
is cold and that that has really become a
formula to describe both Francis and less
Dominic though they are the so called
I give it to you in Latin
and translate it in English.
We call them the clowns
of the Lord your clitoris.
They are the clowns do
plethora's low money, uh, uh,
uh, the counsel of the Lord of
this to say they're playing,
they're playing at the world, the
play with the world. They bring in a,
or we could call a perspective
of play in the world.
They are making fun of the world.
They are challenging the values of the
world and in this sense they bring out
that which becomes the most
impressive aspect of their theology,
which is that of a playful theology.
We'll talk more about this.
The notion that God plays the
creation itself is a spectacle.
I call it a field drama. The idea
that God is not, it's, it doesn't,
it doesn't deprive the
divinity of its seriousness,
but makes that citizens part of a world
of joy. That's the, that's the whole,
the aesthetics, the new aesthetics
that, uh, Francis managers to release.
And Dominic managers also too.
It's kind of playful idea of the world,
a comedy I or not.
I tried to explain to you from the
very first day when we got together how
complicated was for me at the time to
explain why Dante causes texts the comedy
versus saw sublime. It seems to be,
it's talking about how the ordinary,
a plain man of the year,
around the year,
1300 managers have the most sublime of
experiences. And I said, yes, of course.
This is about the happy ending because
comedy at all was the genre of happy
ending.
It is about the low level of experiences,
about the vulgar language and until users,
but the real and substantial reason for,
uh,
Dante calling his poem a comedy and
for the readers using the attributes of
divine was exactly.
It's exactly that,
a way of responding to these, uh, uh,
sense of, uh, the joyful
quality of creation. That's,
that's the point.
So for all the series,
for all the horror that we have been
witnessing through hell and purgatory,
joy seems to be that were
told which Dante is moving,
nor a tragic vision. Plus once you
play off, once you think of play,
you can no longer have the tragic vision
because you understand that the tragic
vision is part of something
larger. It is, it is, it is part,
it's a vicissitudes, you
know, comedies and tragedies.
Elledge allergies are all linked to the
wheel of fortune in medieval iconology
you keep going around, but they are
all part of something really larger,
which is this playful theologies
[inaudible] ludicrous,
uh, that, uh, that he
has been incompetent, uh,
that has been preparing for us. Let
me just go on with, uh, a few more.
Uh, uh, the, the, uh,
a few more details here, a
couple of minutes and then, uh,
uh, this relationship
now of, uh, um, the, the,
the other issue that, uh,
really and retrospectively,
another issue that Dante is raising,
let me just talk about this, uh,
in the cantor of Dominic,
much more than he did
in the Canto of Francis.
This is really unique.
It is Eric presentation
in terms of language.
It is a safe whatever orthodoxy Dominic
stents for because that's why what the
Dominicans, the Dominicans were
the intellectual arm of the church.
There were,
as I said,
founded with a specific purpose of
entering the universities and debating the
various points of view.
There were the Aristotelian,
so they were the poets that were
traditionally the troublemakers of,
of the, where the, the, the,
the, the, uh, the figures, the,
the philosophers and so on. Uh, and
especially in Paris, that's the, the,
the, the university. Uh, so those are,
there is an idea of orthodoxy
with Dominic and yet here,
the whole representation takes place in,
it takes place in terms of language and
they didn't give you a couple of example
examples,
uh,
around lines 80 many time his nurse found
him silent in the week on the ground.
This is part of this, allow that
CEO this and you'll now of a, of,
of Dominic as if he said
for this and my calm, oh,
father of him,
Felicia Felix,
indeed or mother of him.
Giovan indeed if interpreted
it means what they say.
Dante's playing with etymologist
here or the father is really happy.
There is a relationship between the name
and his State of mind and the mother is
meaning God, the one who is full of
grace. Jovana the one who comes before,
uh,
is also if you interpreted properly
this to say orthodoxy or heresy.
Yeah,
pink. It's, it's, it's flip
side, right? Head his head north.
It could've been talking about a
seizure of frog broadband's head. I say,
we've been talking about
Joe Kim's all hell is he?
He appears as a question of language,
as a question of what a normal Duh that
is above all a grammatical older and
therefore it needs a kind of correction
or has a kind of ambiguity that you
always assume and your is presumed to
be present within the order of language.
Anything.
In fact,
retrospectively I can say to you that
even the schisms of inferno where we saw
the poet bedtime Thunderball born,
you remember that horrifying picture
of the poet who holds in his own hand,
like a lamb,
his own head and goes home talking to the,
the Virgil and,
and Dante.
Or in that same canto there was the,
the presence of Mohammad who's body
seem to be completely lacerated.
Even the schisms are questions
of language. Our questions,
Dante understands them is issues
of language which doesn't vote,
which only means this to talk
about language and repeat.
They are part of the
imponderable quality of language,
the ambiguities of language,
the force of language and
the power of language. Okay,
so that's uh, that's what I can
tell you about this cantors.
And let me stop here and see if
there are questions that I would
most gladly here if not answer.
But,
uh,
wow.
Please
face to any threat from the
church came in paradise.
The question is,
would Dante have faced
some censorship probably,
uh, from, uh,
from the Church authorities for
placing Joel came in paradise?
Actually, no, not at all.
Because the formula he uses a,
here comes the Calabrian Breon Abbott,
Joe Kim endow that with the gift of
prophecy, more or less. That's, see,
that's translation. It translates their
Latin formula, the spirit to profit,
ethical to tattoo,
which was would already used.
He had been jogging, had
already been exempted of, uh,
the censure of his thought that
are Bonaventure had voiced.
And in, uh, in the mass
in honor of [inaudible],
they will use that formula.
So he's actually using economical
a formula church formula,
uh, for his own, for Joe Gibbs
on, uh, uh, never happened.
He's not saying,
never was I saying,
but what Dante probably of that's what he
did is he should be canonized. Ah, okay.
No. But the answer is, uh,
and that's the reason why, um,
he could not have faced
any, um, any reprimands.
Yes.
With Saint Francis and
forensics as a form of freedom when
you went to freedom is Ernesto,
when you went and harmony,
it becomes more free.
Can we make that or how can we link
his own poverty and how
are we supposed to be thinking about Dante
having to depend on,
I guess the charity of others?
Um,
the good the question is,
I was talking about poverty as
being a state of freedom. Um,
uh, in the Canto of France's, uh, would I,
we're supposed to also,
uh,
associate Dante's own fate of poor exile
beggar that he was during his exile in
that description. That's, that's the
question. And I would say yes, of course.
The, uh, poverty,
I hope I explained mean several
things for, for Dante born,
eventual going thinking about poverty
of language over till philosophy, uh,
et cetera. But all of them understand
poverty in a very literal way.
But all of them understand the one thing
that this kind of poverty is really a
description of the human condition
to begin with. We are all poor.
That's the primary sense.
We are all born or defective
and it need wherever needs,
where some of us gone being needy or,
and we are all our lives,
right? So this is a general
understanding of the idea of poverty.
But then there is a sort of,
uh,
the other side of this and the other
side is that it's actually a blessing
because it's the state of freedom. This
is really very much like what you expect,
the philosophical, philosophical
freedom, you know, without any cares,
even Horace,
I don't want to have wealth and,
and start worrying about having the
cares about how the stock market is doing
today are not doing. Um, so I want
to be completely free of that.
And it's a state of freedom. It's
downhill. So thinking about himself,
does it have a consolatory note for him
to believe that after all I'm not alone?
Yes, yes. I would say, uh, that's,
that's the case in his own life.
Dante,
unlike Petrarch who really die,
the poet who follows few
years after Dante, he did,
he died one of the wealthiest man of
his time by virtue of being a poet,
a writer, and so on. Dante
never got to that point.
I mean, I'm wondering if we should take
it literally it's sort of, you know,
things about poverty or is it more like a,
an ideal,
like a sort of poetic escape into a
perspective, I guess that he adopts,
like adopting the perspective,
should we take it literally or is,
or just as a poetic way of speaking?
Uh,
I think that I answered that by saying,
but I think you're asking something
else may be, and then I'll get to that.
Since you are the, uh, I think
I'm, as I'm saying that this is,
was really the reality of his life.
Okay.
A standard such as that is bound
to a peer maybe. Well, you know,
you need a little bit of comfort and
consolation and so you say it's a poverty,
but it's,
it's,
it really has the crisp
of a Francis spirituality.
But I'm not trying to
diminish Dante's convictions.
What I think you're really asking is,
I don't know if you really ask you,
I don't know. Uh, but, uh, I know
what you would ask him, but I,
that is another side to your question.
Are you asking me whether or not
he was a Franciscan for instance?
Is that what you're asking?
Because if you are,
that would be a very good question in
the sense that they were a lot of uh,
ideas.
We don't have any evidence,
but a lot of ideas that he became a
member of the third older [inaudible]
Francisco's so that he
practiced therefore truly,
literally in his own life that which
Francis himself had a practice and
preached. So maybe that's what
probably if you weren't asking that,
maybe you should've been asking
that and that would have been,
I would have to say that.
And the question.
So
I have a few minutes.
So yes.
Is this story of the sultan,
those two guys,
are you have Dante religion or
Islam that we took away from the Freddo?
Ah,
that's a very good question.
It's the view of a friends is
going to the sultan a suppose.
Is it meant to revise, uh,
the view that we may have,
uh, uh, formed of Dante's
attitude toward Islam,
reading in Fat and Fennel 28?
Um,
I think so. I think so. I
think my answer is that I,
that's why I was stressing this,
that there is a sort of, uh, uh,
a radical turning that takes place in
Francis operates a change in the way the
Christians and the
Muslims can go on, uh, uh,
thinking of that encounter.
It's no longer through armies if it's
through peaceful discourse from this point
of view. Francis, uh, uh,
care result on a traditional had started
with, uh, Peter the venerable, uh,
there were a few other theologians
who had a kind of view that it was not
through two wars. That
this, uh, kind of, uh, of a,
of a dialogue,
um,
could take place if a war is a form of
dialogue. I'm not sure. Of course the,
uh,
so Dan has acknowledges that in Francis,
and I think that he dramatizes it,
he justice dramatizing the
sense of the, uh, the awareness,
which was very central to Bonaventure of,
uh,
the relationship with the three to him,
the three religions,
the Hindus,
the Christians and the Muslims. Um, and,
and retrospectively,
it forced me to now say things about
schism that I did not say when we were
reading Canto 28 that schism,
we have a presence there of,
you remember all forms of [inaudible].
We have a religious case, ma, uh,
with, uh, Fryer, uh, who decides
who is really enjoy kissed.
By the way, uh, the Chino,
there was a the poet who
by the power of his words,
a thunderbolt of the province.
Our poet divides father from son the king,
the king from the sun, and therefore
breaks the unity of the body politic.
The idea that,
you know,
the king's two bodies in the famous
formula of the book of the Great Historian
Canter, Oh, aerobics, right? So
that he broke that kind of unity.
There is then an allusion
to a story from Lucan. Uh,
one of the soldiers,
cool real,
who broke away from,
uh,
from Pohnpei and he had from Caesar
and he had his own tongue cut.
It's clear that schism is to be
understood linguistically. I am,
I'm, I am not revising my view, but now
I can tell you what I always thought was,
uh, underlying the
representation of even Islam,
which means that even the
interpretation of Mohammed in 28,
horrifying though it as, as, as, as it is,
it appears if Mohammed was the one
who was doubling the existing unity,
that's it. That's it. Through
the power of speech. That's,
that's the jewel.
It's a horrifying representation that
does not take anything away from that.
But clearly you see that the damnedest
understanding of these issues is a little
bit more nuanced that it made for s side.
A foresight appear when we come
later in the heaven of justice.
And before we get to heaven with justice.
Dentist goes on talking about the warrior,
and he begins with Joshua
the, the, the, the, the,
the hero who brings about
the destruction of Jericho.
Uh, etc. And then, but he
also mentions the crusaders.
Uh, so there is a kind of, uh,
ambiguity that I would say that he,
he still values what he
thinks is the heroic life.
Nonetheless, after I say this, let me
just state another poet about Dante.
That's true. That clearly he's
talking from a Christian standpoint.
There's no question about this,
but the underlying spirituality of Dante
is what I call the spirituality of the
desert.
Dante's truly the poet of the desert in
the sense that in the desert you have
modes of request that where everyone
is really going because whatever we are
going, we are always going to the
absolute whatever journey we may take.
Its whole is the same journey. And so
the spirituality of the quest sort of,
I wouldn't say overhauls,
but at least tempers,
this idea of Dante being so strict and
firm in this universe of degrees and
distinctions that he sets up.
I don't know if I
clarified this for you.
Okay. Thank you so much.